So what caused the civil war?
Somebody said slavery.
Can I hear a states rights?
Can I hear a conflicting civilizations?
Can I hear Onassis Fury?
Can I hear fanaticism?
Can I hear fear?
Can I hear stupidity?
Can I hear God?
Damn.
Yankees
or
Jefferson Davis may have captured the kind of toxin that was in the air around
southern succession and late 1860 and into
this distracted,
sad years.
Whitman called it of 1861 Jeffers and Dave as soon to be first president only
president of the confederate states of America senator,
former senator from Mississippi,
former commandant of West Point,
former secretary of war.
He tried to capture what the south was doing with succession with a certain
dignified reserve.
Here.
This is at the very end of 1860 before Mississippi had succeeded,
but it's not far away.
He said the south now quote is confronted by a common foe.
The south should buy the instinct of self preservation.
Be United.
The recent declarations of the candidate and leaders of the Black Republican
Party and southerners made no miss no opportunity to rename the Republican Party
a thousand times the Black Republican Party.
At any rate,
the reason declaration of the candidate and leaders of the Republican,
the Black Republican Party must suffice to convince many who have formerly
doubted the purpose to attack the institution of slavery in the states.
The undying opposition to slavery in the United States means war upon it,
where it is not where it is not.
That is the Republicans did not simply opposed slavery in the territories.
They opposed slavery and the slave states and they would not stop until they had
obliterated it and the time is at hand.
One of the great battle is to be fought between the defenders of the
constitutional government and the voters of mob rule,
fanaticism,
and anarchy.
No.
David seemed to think a little bit was at stake for the south in 1861 however,
after the war,
Jefferson Davis rope what is probably the longest,
most Turgid belabored 1200 page defense of a failed political revolution in the
history of language.
1,279 pages is his memoir entitled the rise and fall of the confederate
government
and by the time he wrote that are published in 1882
he was arguing everywhere on storied famous legendary tours of the sound.
The war had absolutely nothing to do with slavery.
Listen to just one cast of that 1200 page defense of his constitutional
movement.
Slavery said Jeff Davis by 1882 was the no wise the cause of the conflict but
only an incident.
Generally African American,
excuse me.
Generally Africans were born the slaves of barbarian masters untaught in all the
useful arts and occupations reared and he even darkness and sold by he than
masters.
They were transferred to shores enlightened by the raise of Christianity.
Now he goes on.
All right,
quoting
black set.
Jeff Davis had been quote,
put to servitude,
trained in the gentle arcs,
the peace and order in civilization.
They increased from a few unprofitable savages to millions of efficient
Christian labors.
Their survival instincts rendered them contented with their lot and their
patient toilet.
Bless the land of their abode with unmeasured riches.
There strong local and personal attachment,
secured faithful service.
Never was there.
Happier dependence of labor and capital on each other.
The tempter came like the serpent of Eden and decoyed them with the magic word
freedom.
He put arms in their hands and train their humble but emotional natures to deeds
of violence and bloodshed and sent them out to devastate their benefactors.
I could go on and on with this particular incredible passage.
What you have there in that 1882 passage is the core,
the lifeblood of the lost cause tradition.
Okay?
In 1861 and you've read Charles Duhigg's book on this in 1861 southern
leadership at least until after Fort Sumpter,
argued every day in every way that they were about the business of preserving a
slave society,
civilization based on slave labor or racial system ordered by slavery now
threatened by these antislavery black Republicans in the wake of the civil war.
However,
so much energy will be exercise,
not only by southerners over time to try to convince the American people and the
rest of the world that this event was not about slavery
in a speech in 1878 like many other speeches he gave him the last third of his
life.
Frederick Douglass was at that point 1878 already fed up with lost cars,
arguments about what the war had been about.
He was also already early in the process fed up or the ways in which Americans
were beginning to reconcile this bloody terrible conflict around the mutual
valor of soldiers and in his view,
forgetting what the whole terrible thing might have even been about.
And the end of a magnificent speech.
You gave it a veterans reunion.
He said this,
the civil war,
this is Frederick Douglass was not a fight between rapacious birds and ferocious
beast.
Amir display a brute courage and endurance.
It was a war between men of thought as well as the action and in dead earnest
for something beyond the battlefield.
He went on and on and on.
Then to declare that the war had been about ideas
and he described the difference and the difference between those ideas as he put
it was the difference between quote,
barbarism and civilization.
Now I'm going to spend this lecture just reflecting with you on first succession
because I left you hanging in the air about the various explanations of
succession interpretations over time.
I don't want to revisit that at least briefly and then I want to take you
through a little quick survey of the interpretations of civil war causation over
time.
It's fascinating to understand how in the past now nearly a century and a half
Americans have gone through this topsy turvy twisting inside out changing view
of what causes that war.
The backtest.
The session I left off with saying I was going to offer you five different
explanations.
I don't think they're all equal,
um,
necessarily,
but they're there in some ways.
They kind of fold into one another and I'd already talked about how the
preservation of slavery,
a slave society,
a society ordered by slave labor and so forth,
um,
was a principal,
if not the principle,
purpose of this secession movement,
at least in the deep south where it's succeeded.
Remember now there are still eight slave states that have not succeeded from the
Union as of March,
1861 when Lincoln was to be inaugurated,
the majority of the slave states are still in the union,
not out only South Carolina,
over to Texas,
the whatever color that is of the deep south was the confederate states of
America.
Had it remained only those seven states.
It's hard to imagine exactly how the confederacy would have mounted a war effort
conducted or and created a foreign policy and managed.
If the Lincoln government decides
on war or coercion as the south,
we'll call.
It is hard to imagine how the confederacy would have survived as long as it did.
The four states that will join it,
we'll come to this on Thursday,
do not succeed.
Of course,
until after Fort Sumpter,
Virginia,
North Carolina,
Tennessee and Arkansas in their initial secession legislatures or conventions,
either did not chose not to vote or voted succession down,
which Virginia decisively did before fort Sumpter.
And it's only after the firing.
Unfortunately,
her in April of 61 Virginia will votes to session.
And it's crucial of course,
given that it's Virginia,
the size of Virginia,
the significance and symbolism and power of Virginia Geogra geographical
location of Virginia.
And so on a second explanation of succession though is what I would call the
fear thesis,
fear of many kinds.
And now this is of course,
deeply related to the first explanation of preserving a slave society.
But in some ways this was a racial fear as well.
If you look into those slavery convention,
uh,
succession conventions,
and if you look deeply into ohs quotations and Charles Book and he loads of the
mine,
you doesn't,
he,
there's an uneven,
more immediate kind of racial fear among southern secessionists that they live
on PR on the potential of a racial powder keg of the potential of slave
insurrection over time,
especially if the south and the slavery continues to shrink within itself.
There's the phrase they kept returning to,
and Abraham Lincoln's house divided speech from 1858 they never let him forget
it,
that,
that he and the Republican Party,
they said,
well,
we're going to put slavery on a quote course of ultimate extinction.
That's fairly clear,
isn't it?
We're going to make your system extinct.
I like that.
Oh,
not a problem.
Um,
fear of the radicalism now of a John Brown,
John Brown had sort of made a,
this equation that had always been there in the southern mine in vague ways.
Um,
explicit.
If the Republican party in the North had succeeded in selling this slogan of a
slave power conspiracy.
Well southerners now the planter class and the secessionist are very successful,
especially in the wake of John Brown's raid of selling a mutual or a counter
conspiracy theory.
And that conspiracy simply is abolition emissaries.
There are lots of labels that goes by,
but the idea that if the Republican politicians themselves aren't going to lead
bands into the south to attack the south,
they will end up nevertheless politically stimulating more and more.
John Brown's to make visitations on the sounds
all over the rhetoric of succession.
You find the language of,
or the word frankly of submission submission,
we will not submit and so on.
Let me give you just one example.
Um,
in Charleston,
South Carolina,
the editor of its most radical newspaper,
it's most succession as newspaper.
It was a man named Robert ret and the Charleston courier,
I'm sorry,
the Charleston Mercury is what he edited and he ran a series of articles under
the heading,
the terrors of submission during the session,
winter.
And in one of those pieces,
Robert Rhett wrote,
and I quote,
if the south once submits to the rule of abolitionists by the general
government,
there is probably an end of all peaceful separation of the union.
We can only escape the ruin.
They meditate for the south by war.
The ruin of the south by the emancipation of her slaves is not like the ruin of
any other people.
It is not a mere loss of liberty,
but it is a loss of liberty property,
home country.
Everything that makes life worth living.
Rent was full of some anxious fury.
Without a doubt,
there were southern secessionists who absolutely believed that even any
discussion of slavery's future in the u s congress,
it should be suppressed.
They would no longer live in a union.
They even discussed what to do about the future of slavery.
Yeah,
and I,
I would say there's not only a kind of racial fear,
fear of loss of,
of,
of slavery by the planter class,
but there's a certain kind of political fear going on as well.
And that is the fear that southern Paul's now had.
They'd had this for years,
hadn't they?
The fear was the growing or the growth now for them of a kind of minority status
that that Republican Party in the north now I had the potential given the
population of the north,
this sectional and isolate every party.
I had the potential to really take over the House of Representatives in huge
numbers.
Then you get Lincoln in the White House for four years.
And what if you get him for eight?
And he points the next two,
three,
four,
five members of the Supreme Court and he can control the diplomatic corps around
the world.
And even more importantly,
he can control patronage of the post office system,
which in those years,
believe it or not,
was a very powerful,
nobody gives a hoot about who runs a toaster offices now.
But boy they did then.
And what was at stake,
and we can see this all over their letters,
their diaries and their speeches,
succession conventions was a loss ultimately for the slave holding class of what
uh,
James Roark and other scholars have called plantar control.
So to say,
you know,
succession is about slavery.
Is,
is accurate,
but there layers beneath it
and what I'd call a kind of fear thesis.
A third explanation is what we might call or a motivation for southern
succession.
Well,
we might call southern nationalism a sense of southern unity,
uh,
a dream for some southern secessionists.
They were a minority,
surely over time.
And they're even a minority,
I think in the midst of the succession crisis,
but a dream over time of a southern nation and independence,
uh,
of,
of course,
of developing their own boundaries and their own potential expansionist foreign
policy
where they would no longer ever be dependent on the United States federal
government on one compromise after another with northerners and now to many
southern secessionists,
it would be compromises with people that couldn't even conceive of compromising
with these free soil.
Antislavery they believed abolitionist Republicans,
these southern nationalists.
We're led by people like,
I hadn't been Ruffin,
a Virginia William Lounges,
UNC of Georgia,
Robert Red of South Carolina,
uh,
James DB,
Dubbo,
who published the dubose review,
a very important southern magazine out of New Orleans.
It was a vision now of an independent southern nation.
In fact,
Edmund Ruffin was so determined to try to,
to gather the spirit of an independent southern nation than in the wake of John
Brown's raid.
He got,
he got himself to Harper's ferry and managed to collect 15 or 20 of old John
Brown's pikes.
You know,
these beer things the John Brown was going to give to slaves after his rebellion
and Ruffin sent one of those pipes to the governor of every southern state.
Well,
people were into symbolism.
No,
it's interesting that the sense of a southern ne nationalism,
if you like,
was born more,
I would argue,
a fear of an enemy than it actually was at any kind of planned vision of an
organized nation.
Okay.
As numerous brilliant scholars of southern nationalism from drew Faust,
the John mccartle and others have argued,
and I will come back to this in a couple of weeks,
uh,
southern nation did come out of this confederacy,
but it was born almost over night and not by a lot of longterm planning,
it was born more and resentment and defensiveness of knowing what they were
against and who their enemy might be.
Then it was actually born of a thought out plan of what they were for.
As also there was also a theory at root at the root of this kind of southern
nationalist fledgling as it wasn't a succession crisis that it's right there in
the succession debate.
It's rooted in the shrinking south theory is rooted in the,
the,
the desire to preserve a slave society.
But it's the idea that the south ultimate welfare wouldn't be better outside of
the union than in
requiring a certain thinking about how to create a new nation.
A possible explanation though I wouldn't hang too many hats on this one cause
it's rather vague.
It used to have a lot of um,
um,
purchase among historians.
There's what we might call agrarianism the agrarian thesis.
Uh,
the idea of king cotton videology or king cotton diplomacy,
um,
or put more deeply a kind of Jeffersonian yeoman idealism.
This is the vague theory that succession was to protect and agrarian
agricultural planter civilization
that the south was ultimately they like to think of themselves.
Even the leadership as,
um,
a people or a republic of farmers,
small farmers.
Now,
the majority of them were small farmers.
The real south,
this argument was,
was not in the slave owning masterclass,
but in the men of the soil protecting a way of life against all that ignoble go
getter,
money grubbing,
Yankee individualism.
There's something to this.
You can find these arguments all over the succession debates as well.
Separate from those New Yorkers,
they're gonna take your wallet
or is the same when you can hit a Yankee,
you wouldn't hit you back,
but it would suit you.
This kind of real vogue back in this interpretation back in the 1920s,
thirties,
forties,
even into the 1950s and beyond among the stories like frank [inaudible] and
others.
Um,
and it,
and it's spirit,
if you like,
is there in the confederate anthem,
not Dixie,
but the other confederate anthem,
the Bonnie blue flag.
You don't hear that as much,
but there's a,
there's a verse in Bonnie Blue Flag that the soldier sang all the time.
It goes like this and listen for its ironies.
We are a band of brothers native to the soil,
fighting for the property.
We gained by honest toil
who's honest,
toil,
property.
Well for a yeoman farmer,
that lyric
make good sense.
And fifth,
you can also argue this is the session is deeply rooted in some,
some have argued this certainly Bertram Wyatt Brown has and others is rooted in
um,
this notion of a tradition of southern honor.
The thesis that at the heart of the southern planter class in particular,
uh,
the,
at the heart of their cohesion,
there's self understanding in their worldview was a set of values by which men,
especially planters defined themselves and therefore their society.
And once those values were threatened,
they circled the wagons in defense.
These were the manly virtues.
The argument went of honesty,
trustworthiness and titled Social Rank,
the willingness to defend one's honor,
blood lineage,
family and especially home or home land to defend one's community against not
only invasion,
but also insult or humiliation
to save face and the presence of one's critics,
one's enemies,
nothing could be worse.
They are said the honor code,
then public humiliation disputes to the man of southern honor.
We're personal,
not a matter of law.
And there comes a time,
the argument went,
what the hell were the supreme court to hell with compromises in Congress?
This is personal.
They said,
no,
this is,
this one's hard to throw darts at and make it stick.
A,
you can see the language in the succession movement.
We must defend our honor.
We must defend our society.
When is the southern secessionists planter speaking from honor and when is he
speaking from the preservation of the slave society and why is he speaking from
his sense of agrarianism?
When is he speaking from a,
from a vision of a,
of a,
an independent southern national future is,
is never easy to know,
but you can hear it in a James Jones,
for example,
a leading South Carolina secessionist in the South Carolina secession convention
who got up at the end of the arguments and he said,
well folks,
quote,
if we fail,
we have saved our honor and lost nothing.
I think of the logic there because he doesn't really know precisely at what
they're going to fail.
That if a whole civilization goes down and ashes,
if a society will be
destroyed at its root,
you've lost nothing.
Some of these same guys who were so caught up in defense of honor,
of course loves Shakespeare.
They especially love plays like the fourth
on Prince Harry's watch during his soldiers to die with honor because if you die
with honor,
you've lost nothing.
No.
And your and more modern sensibilities.
Life usually doesn't equate with nothing.
Okay.
But Mix all those explanations up together and folding a little ambiguity and
you can begin to explain succession.
A final parting word though.
Um,
yeah.
Did the south of the right to secede.
That's just out of a show of hands that,
just to show it,
this is just a pole.
Did the southern states have the right to succeed in 1861?
Yes.
Hmm.
All right.
No
bunch of Yankees.
Not sure the people are honest because this is a constitutional theory that,
uh,
is,
is very old and never ending.
Not sure.
Down here on the front,
a teaching assistant is not sure.
So,
and he's remaining not sure.
David Houston is a prophet of ambiguity.
Yeah.
Got To watch him.
He Burns question marks on your front porch,
you know,
if you're not careful.
Yeah.
I usually save that Joe for Unitarians.
But anyway,
nevermind.
Okay.
Uh,
sorry.
Sorry.
I know
very quickly though,
in 1861,
of course people had to make huge decisions.
You're not the least of which was Lincoln and his circle of Republican advisers.
But Lincoln was very clear on this.
We're going to come back on Thursday to this whole question of
what Lincoln's policy was there.
An April,
1861,
and why he moved with,
uh,
with some force against the south.
But first of all,
Lincoln's view and the Nationalist Union,
this view of succession was essentially this,
and you can read this closely and your Lincoln reader in many places,
but it was basically that the union of the United States.
So the argument was created by the people,
not the states.
I know this gets a little bit like constitutional hair splitting,
but a lot of hairs that were at stake.
So you had to split some of them.
The union was created,
said this argument by the people,
not by the states.
The union was there for older than those states that agreed to join it
in the American revolution and in the US Constitution,
we the people in order to form a more perfect union,
some union has argued meant succession really is not possible.
There was the practical argument against the session or union cannot survive.
The argument went,
if it can be broken,
it will.
Whenever someone gets upset,
I don't like this law and that law.
Oh,
I like these,
but I don't like those.
I will know if I those and not participate.
The argument is that's not a good practical way to run a republic.
Okay.
And some unionists in Lincoln was of course brilliant at this.
Eventually,
as you read his speeches would argue against the session from a position sort of
of civil religion,
of almost mysticism.
What did Lincoln referred to at the end of that first inaugural?
That magnificent phrase about the mystic chords of memory.
I remember at battlefield and Patriot grave would yet swell the chorus of the
union.
That's about music and memory.
Not about the constitution.
Unionists would invoke the fathers just like this.
The section as well of course,
and those fathers of the Constitution and the American republic,
they would argue
were nationalist.
They wanted a more perfect union out of a union that wasn't at all perfect
and sometimes they would even directly invoke chief justice John Marshall,
the Virginians first,
Greg,
Chief Justice Supreme Court for 25 30 years and the forging of that institution
of the Supreme Court into a national institution of cohesion and a certain
power.
No,
the state's riotous does.
The succession is to,
of course we'll argue.
No,
no.
They will say constitutionally the Union they will argue is a federal union
federal in the sense that it was a compact,
a contract between its founders and the founders were the states.
The chose to join it and they will argue that states voted
in the continental congress.
States voted in an articles of confederation.
States voted to approve the u s constitution or nuts.
States voted to ratify the constitution and so on.
Then they will do,
they will go to the reserve clause of the constitution.
All powers,
not given to the federal government.
In,
in,
in the constitution,
in Congress are quote reserved for the states,
that beautiful,
wonderful,
tortured and
ambiguous,
but in some ways brilliant provision of the constitution.
They will go to the language of experiment in republicanism.
They will say the American republic has been an experiment.
It's been a fascinating,
wonderful,
you know,
world historical experiment.
But you know what?
They'll say it's just failed.
And let us show you the reasons why and the way,
and uh,
let us go in peace.
It is our right,
they will argue for the right of succession based on essentially the notion of a
contractual theory of government
and that a contract in this sense they will argue,
can
be broken.
Now
as Alan Nevins once said,
succession though,
after all the constitutional historians and the lawyers have worked it through,
okay,
as a matter of power
and as Kevin said,
who has the most guns?
Okay,
I'll leave that hanging from mom.
We'll come back to succession and the wake Fort Sumpter and the beginning of the
war on Thursday.
But let me take you through a quick survey of what historians have done with
this story over time.
Uh,
I love this kind of stuff.
The historic graphical debates of his storage is probably why some of us become
a storage.
We liked the arguments
before at least states' rights though.
It's of course the theory.
There's not going to at all die and the civil war,
it's the session may have died.
Well maybe I'm never saying never.
Who knows Casa vote,
just seceded from Serbia and Russia is making a big stink over it
and on him.
And I was listening to a Canadian radio station last night.
Don't ask me why,
but it's what comes on right after NPR goes off.
And the quarterback,
coy and Quebec are using the cost of all model now to rev up once again the
possibility of Quebec succession from Canada.
So watch out gotta follow this.
Okay.
There's always threats after some of our elections,
somebody deciding sue,
they want us to seed,
which usually means that it's want to move to New Zealand.
But New Zealand has strong immigration laws,
so don't even think it
states rights is a theory.
I'm going to argue a theory of the proper relations of the levels of government,
how power is distributed between those levels of government.
It is a theory of the nature of federalism,
but,
and I think this is the crucial point,
and you can argue this,
we can argue this forever and we probably will if we're Americans,
but I would argue that the significance of states' rights is always an
everywhere in the cause to which it is employed.
Yeah,
states' rights for what
a state's right to do what in the interest of what.
Okay.
Now throughout our history,
some things have happened first in steaks.
Women's suffrage happened in states first and then grew over time and to finally
a federal right to vote for women.
There are many other cases.
States' rights is not always the conservative or reactionary idea.
It is sometimes a progressive idea when my believe in more local state control,
but to what end?
For what purpose?
The advanced what issue cards,
what principle take.
Just make your list of issues.
And where would you start first for stem cell research?
For gay marriage,
for or against?
Where did the right begin
school curriculums,
right to vote,
women's economic rights,
reproductive freedom,
collective bargaining for unions and on and on and on.
Old Age pensions began in first in some states and the progressive here before
we ever had a national social security,
the civil war didn't eliminate the states' rights.
It has this sloganeering power to,
it never gets much analysis.
Well,
all right.
Now somewhere on this outline,
I listed
well in the wake of the civil war,
of course in for that generation there were unionists and confederate blame
laying interpretations of the war.
It's a fascinating collection of writing and if a lot of it,
many of it is score,
much of it is score settling.
Of course,
it's vindication on the part of southerners.
It's the forging of this loss cause tradition.
And I'll speak a lot more about that at the very end of the course.
Cause the loss caused,
became an elaborate ideology over time,
especially a racial ideology.
Um,
a lot of the debate about among the generation that fought the war of,
of what had caused it got all caught up in labeling was the war,
the war of the rebellion,
which was the official northern federal definition and label of the war.
This was not called the American civil war by the federal government.
It was called the war of the rebellion.
If you go out and look at civil war monuments on battlefields put up in the
1880s and nineties it's called the war of the rebellion.
If it's a union monument in the south,
it was early called the war between the states.
It was sometimes called the war for southern independence.
It was sometimes called the war of northern aggression at sometimes is used now
as a euphemism.
My favorite label,
and it wasn't just southern,
but by the 1890s and turn of the 20th century,
a label that got into the press and people love that as a throwaway joke line
was quote the late unpleasantness.
You want to start dissolving conflict.
We had some late unpleasantness here and slaughtered all these people,
but nevermind.
Now I'll pass on on examples of this union is in confederate tradition and
perhaps we'll just revisit this at the end of the course cause that's perhaps
where it belongs anyway.
But by the late 19th century,
the 1890s to be exact in into the early 20th century,
one historian named James Ford Rhodes
and it's kind of nationalist tradition in which he wrote had a tremendous impact
on the way the vast majority of Americans would come to understand civil war
causation.
Rhodes was a gifted amateur.
Um,
a gentleman scholar,
he was born in Cleveland,
Ohio in 1848 so he was a boy and a teenager during the civil war,
but too young do a fart.
But he grew up,
helplessly fascinated with this event that forged his life,
his world.
He's very wealthy.
He retired to Beacon Hill in Boston in between 1893 in 1907,
a 14 year period.
He published his seven volumes,
a series called history of the United States from the compromise of 1850.
They didn't worry about boring titles in the 19th century.
That title would never fly through a publisher today.
But that's what it was called,
seven volumes roads road.
Now on the one hand road said the civil war was caused,
he,
he developed a sole cause theory and he said,
look,
stole cars is slavery making a mistake.
It's slavery,
but it's what roads did with this that is really important and it is still alive
and well in our culture and you can't kill it.
He said the world was caused by slavery.
It was an irrepressible conflict,
but he focused on slavery as a system.
I'm cotton and the cotton gin,
not upon any moral element to the story of slavery and or abolition.
Slavery was a national Kersey called it never a national crime.
Slavery was a broad force,
almost like climate.
It was almost like bad weather
and no one is to blame for bad weather.
Okay.
Southerners deserved and roads view sympathy and not censure slave holders,
he argues should be absolved because they were themselves,
the victims of the system and therefore the victims of history.
Yeah,
a tragic lot.
Okay.
Destined to try to preserve a civilization that the world was beginning to pass
by.
He greatly admired antebellum southern society and civilization.
And there's a certain,
a stallion roads as well.
Oh my God.
What we lost in the great planters world.
Okay.
He Rose Robert,
he lead or the status of national hero.
Okay.
He didn't do it alone.
There are a lot of people helping him and helping him with that by 1900.
Okay.
That's Robert E.
Lee who led the confederate armies to national hero.
I just thought I'd point that out.
I was in Richmond two weeks ago giving a lecture.
A woman came up afterward from New York or Boston,
born and raised in the north and she has just moved to Richmond.
Uh,
she's just full of enthusiasm and she's the cultural attache director or
something for the city of Richmond now.
And I'm speaking about this new museum,
about the civil war.
And she came up to me and she thought,
I want to know what you think of my idea that I think the first thing we need to
do in Richmond,
it's just turned on old confederate monument.
Yep.
That's it.
Oh,
oh dear.
Oh dear.
I,
I didn't even know what to tell her.
She just,
just,
just take,
if you could just take down that Robert E.
Dot.
Lee Statue and then that stonewall Jackson state.
Just take them down.
Wouldn't everything be all right?
I went over in the bookstore,
I got her a copy of race and reunion.
This book I did on civil war memory and I said,
here,
here man,
just start here.
According to James Ford Rhodes,
both sides at Fort ennobling,
both sides at fort well,
there was to be no blame.
Okay.
In this historical verdict of seven volumes and something like 3000 and some
pages in roads is history.
Now this put in place and I'll leave it there.
A kind of nationalist reconciliation,
just quasi scholarly popular historical tradition through which most other
interpretations of the civil war causation would now have to pass or breathe or
move.
Then came Charles Beard and Mary Beard by the 1930s.
I'm early in the 20s.
Uh,
how to sum up beard Charles Beard,
the great progressive historian,
so called.
And by that label we mean those historians who came of age around the turn of
the 20th century,
first decade or two of the 20th century,
and we're still writing into the 1950s some of them even into the 60s they
tended to see the world,
especially by the 1930s.
Um,
they tended to see the world through a frame of the Great Depression
while the frame of World War One and then a frame of the crash of 29 and the
worldwide Great Depression of the 30s.
They tended to see history as essentially a story of economics,
essentially a story of capital and labor of wealth as an engine or the pursuit
of it as an engine of history.
Charles Beard wrote a great book in many ways.
We now can look at it and see all kinds of holes in it.
A book call the economic interpretation of the American civil war.
He saw the south and the north is essentially two economies to civilizations,
to economies.
There are rarely any people and I'll spirits work.
There are economies does or other systems.
There are economic forces.
There's cotton and free labor.
There's shipping and merchants in the north and their planters in the south.
There's the telegraph spreading across the north.
There are canals and there were railroads
and in his interpretation,
the south rebelled to try to preserve its economic way of life
and ultimately the civil war and beards view wasn't really about any particular
ideology,
but that is any,
any racial ideology or any pro slavery or antislavery ideology.
It was two economic systems living together in the same society,
the same nation and coming into conflict with one another in unsolvable ways.
Forces meeting at a crossroads and they had the clash.
Beard is laden with inevitability
as
any great economic determinist
usually is.
He called the American civil war,
famously the second American revolution,
but by that he didn't mean what Bruce Levine and Eric Foner and other many other
historians of,
well,
my generation and the generation before have called it when we've called it a
second American revolution would beard meant by that is the kind of great
dividing line between an agricultural era and an industrial era.
All right,
my clock says,
I'm running out of time.
I'm going to leave you hanging on this limb of wondering what the needless wars
school people arguing.
They thought it was needless actually,
but I want to end with this as a lead into Thursday.
Walt Whitman wrote a poem about this year.
He called at 1861 and here are just a few lines of it to give you a sense.
I think Whitman has no one else could captured what was in the heads of
northerners and southerners
armed year years,
the struggle,
no dainty rhymes or sentimental love versus for you.
Oh,
terrible year,
not us,
some pale poet link seated at a desk.
Lisping cadenzas piano,
but as a strong man,
erect,
clothed in blue clothes,
advancing,
carrying a rifle on your shoulder with weld gristle body and sunburnt face and
hands with a knife in the belt that your side,
as I heard you shouting loud,
your son or his voice ringing across the continent year that suddenly saying,
by the miles of the round lipped cannon,
I repeat you hurrying crashing.
Sad,
distracted.
You
see you Thursday.